well that's a good start thank you very
much good good good evening I'm Bradley
Graham I'm the co-owner of politics and
prose along along along along with my
wife Alyssa Muscatine and on behalf of
the entire PNP staff welcome thank you
so much for coming what what a marvelous
crowd and what and what a great space
for a book event thanks to the Warner
Theater for making this spacious place
available as much as we at P & P do
enjoy hosting our authors at our store
on Connecticut Avenue Northwest we had a
feeling we had a feeling that a somewhat
larger venue would be needed for this
one in fact in fact this is the largest
author talk that P & P has ever
sponsored and tickets and tickets sold
out in a matter of minutes so
congratulations you all are the lucky
ones since since its release a week ago
what happened Hillary Clinton's new book
about the 2016 election has landed on
the bestseller list and generated
seemingly non-stop commentary and
conversation some things never change
Hillary has given a number of media
interviews about the book but tonight
she's here with us in person for what is
the first stop on a 15 city tour that
will take her across the United States
and Canada
in the in the in the days and weeks
immediately following the election
Hillary took long walks in the woods
with her dogs consumed more than a few
glasses of chardonnay and tried and
tried to regain her bearings now ten
months later she's back with renewed
strength and fresh purpose and with a
thoughtful and very personal account of
why she lost and the lessons that can be
learned from what was in so many ways a
deeply confounding and disturbing race
many of course are very familiar with
Hillary's long and storied career from
lawyer and advocate for children to
first lady of Arkansas first lady of the
United States u.s. senator from New York
US Secretary of State and the Democratic
Party's presidential candidate
she she she is she is the daughter of
Hugh and Dorothy wife of Bill mother of
Chelsea and grandmother of Charlotte and
Aiden along the way Hillary also has
managed to write books in fact this is
her sixth and reviewers of it so far
seem to agree on at least one thing in
these pages she is less guarded than
ever before more revealing blunt and
authentic she says she didn't intend the
book to be a comprehensive recap of the
campaign and it isn't but it does convey
with raw emotion humor and insight how
it felt to run for president as the
first woman nominated by a major
American political party and how and how
and how it has felt to deal with the
aftermath of a shocking defeat and one
other thing comes through loud and clear
in what happened
Hillary intends to remain active and to
speak out
Hillary Hillary will be in conversation
up here with my wife Lissa the two of
them go back a long way at various times
over the past two and a half decades
Lissa has worked with Hillary as chief
speechwriter communications director
book collaborator and campaign adviser
including several stints helping in the
2016 campaign currently Lissa is writing
her own book about her experiences as
part of Hillary land the small group of
staffers mostly women who started with
Hillary 25 years ago in the White House
and ever and have remained in her orbit
since I'd also like to take a moment to
recognize that in the audience this
evening are a number of members of
Hillary's 2000 campaign staff there
they're out there somewhere they they
toiled mightily for months to help their
candidate earn nearly 3 million more
votes than the Republican nominee
and now and now ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming the woman
who won more than 65 million eight
hundred thousand votes in the last
election Hillary Rodham Clinton
[Applause]
thank you all so much for coming you you
sound like 65 million eight hundred
thousand people which is great and it's
such a great crowd thank you all for
being here and thank you for being here
I feel like we just did this but that
was three years ago we did it for your
your last book hard choices we're back
for what happened it's what happened
it's not what happened question mark
it's not what happened exclamation point
it's not what happened dot dot dot it's
just what happened but congratulations
book number six
by the way produced in record time I
might add and it's a very personal book
which I'm sure those of you who've read
it already know and if you've watched
the interviews and you've heard about it
you know but I just want to say one
thing before we get started of course
it's about the 2016 election and because
Hillary Clinton is Hillary Clinton it of
course delves deeply into a very broad
range of very very important issues from
the erosion of our democratic
institutions the growing science of
totalitarianism creeping into too many
aspects of our lives the rolling back of
voting rights health care environmental
protections economic and social justice
and of course ongoing seemingly daily if
not hourly and more overt examples of
sexism and racism across our country so
what I want to just say as we get
started is that you're you if you don't
have it yet then you're gonna pick your
book up on the way out you know in
Washington there's that thing where you
look in the index and you kind of pick
and choose what you're gonna read start
at the beginning
read all 469 pages because she has a lot
to say
and she has a lot to say about really
really really important challenges
facing this country and if you actually
read from start to finish you will learn
a lot and it's it's just fascinating and
and and really important stuff in the
book so thank you for that but tonight
we're gonna try to keep it a bit more
personal if that's okay and I want to
start really with how this book even
came about and I'm gonna remind you you
may not remember this but you and I had
a conversation way back in the winter
early winter and you mentioned to me
that you were thinking of writing a book
about the election and then we had
several more conversations about this
over the next weeks and months and each
time I said to her emphatically you are
nuts that is a crazy idea why would you
do that
it's way too soon you're still
processing everything we're all still
processing everything I don't know about
the rest of you and I don't know about
you but everybody I know was
experiencing weird things like insomnia
and anxiety gastrointestinal disorders
in fact a friend of mine who's a doctor
in Washington said it's an election
related syndrome known as Trump area
okay so we're all going through all this
right and so I just didn't see how you
could possibly in such a short space of
time and so soon after this election
process all of it for yourself and of
course you're the central act actor in
it so I advised you consistently not to
write it and of course thankfully she
didn't listen to me so that was very
wise on your part and now here we are
with this with this wonderful book and I
just am wondering though how did you
process it so quickly and apparently
this did not involve any therapy along
the way
well that's a sign of something well
actually it was my therapy to be really
clear
lissa has been a friend of mine and a
colleague of mine for a long time now
and is a terrific writer was a great
reporter when she worked for the post
and other publications so I take what
she says very seriously when it comes to
writing and she did come to see me like
a number of my friends who rallied
around came to you know support me just
listen to me vent share their concerns
and worries and I had after the election
as you can read in the book pretty much
nothing I wanted to say to anybody I was
so devastated and it was incredibly
painful and it took weeks of just
getting up everyday cleaning closets
going for walks in the woods all the
things that I did to begin to clear my
head but of course other people were
commenting and writing about the
election and I just didn't think there
was a broad enough view really a
comprehensive understanding of what it
looked like to me in real time and what
I believed happened but I wasn't sure
and I knew it would take a lot of
analysis and evidence gathering and you
know I do kind of believe in facts and
so you know I just began to talk and
listen to people gather information and
I think that it hit me really around the
inauguration people had talked to me
about what are you gonna do and you know
do you write something else and I was
still just trying to muddle through it
really hit me that there were these very
important issues that needed to be
discussed debated even that our
democracy and country relied upon that
kind of self-examination and I thought
well I need to know what happened and I
need to be as honest candid open as I
possibly can in order to figure it out
for myself and maybe doing it in a book
would provide the discipline the
deadline to try to think it through and
so really starting in February I dove in
and I just decided I was going to write
it and it was painful I say in the book
that you know I'd write about something
and I'd have to go lie down because it
was just so hard to think about the
mistakes I made the you know missed
opportunities but then also to come to
grips with these other big forces at
work that I think had a determinant
impact on the outcome so it ended up
being really cathartic for me personally
and from what people are telling me as
I've begun to start doing book signings
and and talking about the book I think
it does provide some catharsis and some
opportunity for reflection for a lot of
other people too and I'm very happy
about that because there are some really
important issues we have to come to
grips with and I wrote it not just to
say what happened but what we need to do
to make sure what happened doesn't
happen again and
what I'm gonna spend a lot of time on
amen
just to follow up for a second on this
how hard it is I mean as I said you're
the central actor and you're writing
about yourself and it obviously was a
you know a mind-boggling experience you
and I share a favorite author and in
Cheryl Strayed I don't know how many of
you have read Wilde or seen the movie
and you have a quote from her in the
book actually but and I think I may have
mentioned to you this one she once said
to me I asked her how do you write about
these things that are so deeply personal
and she said I write to get to a deeper
truth if I'm not gonna be honest with
myself why do I bother to write but
getting to that deeper truth as you've
experienced is hurtful overwhelming
painful could be sad and you have to
deal with things that are intensely
private so I'm just wondering did you
censor yourself at all were there times
when words or thoughts just it was just
too much and you couldn't go there or
what did you do to try to get to that
next level
well I ended up not censoring my
thoughts not censoring what I put into
the book
I will admit I censored some of the
original language oh shucks
you should have left that oh yes some of
those early venting sessions I had a
great team of people who vented with me
and did research for me and helped you
know me better explain what I was
venting about but I didn't hold back at
all on what I saw as you know my own
shortcomings and my deep disappointment
not just for me obviously but for the
country so it was not censored it was
really candid and it was something that
did help me get to some deeper and
bigger truths about me about our country
about some of the really difficult
forces that we have to face the concerns
I have about well I'm sure we'll get
into this
you know everything from sexism and
misogyny and race and the Russians and
you know this voter suppression I mean
there's a lot there that I was learning
as I was writing because when you're in
the middle of a campaign and I know
there are people here who have been
involved in campaigns and for that I
thank you when you're in the middle of
it you are so focused on the immediate
tasks I mean you know what the overall
goal is obviously to win and you've got
your strategies and your tactics lined
up but boy every day is you know 18
hours of just the hardest concentration
and work trying to move it forward it's
hard to lift your head up and sometimes
it's hard to really understand
everything that's happening at the same
time so being able to step back a little
go through it take it apart look at it
analyze it and then write about it
helped me a lot did you did you learn
anything about yourself that you didn't
know you know I really believed that and
it was I think in retrospect it was a
misconception or it was certainly out of
sync with the time in which we're living
and the candidate I ended up running
against because you know I did have this
idea based on my prior experiences in
presidential campaigns really going way
back into the late 60s and 70s that it
mattered greatly if you could make clear
what you wanted to achieve you know
didn't have to have all the details but
that it was important to tell people
what you wanted to do because then when
you were in office they could judge you
on whether or not you were fulfilling
that commitment you made so we spent a
lot of time making sure that everything
I said about policy and how we'd pay for
things and all of that was just
bulletproof because I kept thinking at
some point it's really going to matter
and for all sorts of reasons it didn't
and so I think I stayed way too focused
on a path that was not the direction
that the campaign was heading because of
the pressures from outside forces
because of the reality TV candidate I
was rent running against I think that I
was not as adept or as quick to try to
figure out okay what is a better way for
me to try to communicate this so you
know these are things that you do the
best you can and you think you're
running one kind of campaign and you
realize that the press is not covering
the policy you're putting out every day
they're covering an empty podium and I
kept thinking well we're still going to
break through because people really do
care what kind of jobs and
infrastructure and health care and other
things you want to do for them and their
families and their incomes but there was
a disconnect and so I learned that I
just wasn't I wasn't as I think quick to
trying to make some adjustments along
those lines but you also say in the book
that you developed a new appreciation
for big simple ideas I think that's part
of what you're getting at isn't it well
there's a difference I mean the big
simple ideas I I still believed you know
that a big simple idea like we're gonna
raise taxes on the wealthy that's a big
simple idea and I did have that idea of
very much centered in my current
campaign but there's also I think an
important debate about in politics today
when we have a really intense quick
movement of news and it's a very short
attention span and social media plays a
bigger and bigger part you know trying
to trying to develop a relationship with
voters or to engender confidence and
voters that you
what you're talking about and you're
gonna deliver because you do understand
the complexities may not be as
significant as just repeating those big
ideas over and over again and leaving
the details for later who knows though
by 2020 maybe people will want to know
details again and policy again so you
never know and to be clear she's not
saying big simple ideas without details
just not outlining every single detail
you know ahead of time necessarily which
I just I thought that was a pretty
interesting observation just one other
quick thing about what it feels like
because you're you're so revealing in
the book about what it feels like to be
a presidential candidate of course
you've got constant incoming right good
bad medium you're trying to assess all
sorts of information from all sorts of
people all the time and I it was it was
interesting to me in the book that you
say in a number of places that there
were times when you wish you had struck
back when you've been criticized or
challenged bike by Bernie on Wall Street
and other things by Matt Lauer in that
really awful interview by Comey and then
of course we had the jaws imitation by
Trump on the debate stage you know so in
each of those it sounds like you're oh I
just want to say also by the way even
though you didn't say it do you know how
much it warmed the hearts of tens of
millions of Americans to know that you
thought about saying back up you creep
it's great
but but in those situations it was
really honestly it was just such a
relief to know you were even thinking
about it but in those situations you
weren't able to do that and you felt
yourself constrained you say you felt
like you were in a straightjacket at
times what is it that makes it so hard
to be able to do that in those
situations and I'm sure it has something
to do with being a woman but I'll let
you answer that well I think it does
have a lot to do with being a woman
because it's very hard to be perceived
as strong as opposed to aggressive or
any other word you can think of and so
part of the challenge is how you
modulate how you present yourself in a
mature appropriate way as a woman
seeking a job no other woman has ever
had and I write a whole chapter on being
a woman in politics but much of what I
say goes for being a woman in business
being a woman in any profession it's not
just politics and I think as I tried to
describe my thought process up on that
stage in the second debate
it was hard we had practiced what I
would do if he invaded my space because
we kind of assumed he would because he
had his own issues that he was trying to
you know push through at that time and
so we knew it but once you're there and
it's actually happening to you in real
time in front of you no I don't know 60
million people or something
you are discomforted you are annoyed you
are a little frustrated that he is
stalking you and staring at you and so I
was going back and forth but I had
believed that it's better not to show
that kind of reaction in the middle of a
presidential debate and as you might
think back funny gestures facial
expressions heavy size things really do
affect viewers and I just ended up
believing that in addition to the gender
linked aspect of this there was a
history of people in presidential
debates who had deviated in a way to
show frustration anger dismissiveness
whatever their feelings were and paid a
heavy price for it and I thought
whatever price they paid I would pay
double or triple and so I just thought
okay I'm going to you know I sort of
thought at the end of the day people
would say yeah we really do want
somebody who's calm and composed in the
Oval Office and so I I was aware of all
the different cross currents but I
carried on in a way that I thought was
what a president or someone who wants to
be president should do well and you say
in the book it's and I think you're
referring to longer than this campaign
that you've you sort of have to wear
your composure like a suit of armor and
that that's what you did yeah you know
but you know you know everybody in the
audience knows that feeling that the
next day or the middle of night you wake
up said Oh with only I said that they're
there always is that you mean you do I
thought that the you know it's the
toughest job in the world it's a job
that requires or at least used to
require a level
no curiosity and focus and things that
you'd want to think somebody with that
responsibility would have and I honestly
believe we were in a different kind of
campaign unlike any I'd ever seen before
I mean I've watched people go up and
down in campaigns I've worked in them I
you know was deeply involved obviously
in my husband's two campaigns I am and
flow of a campaign this was really
different and I I don't think anybody
fully grasped how it was a variation on
a presidential campaign unlike any we'd
ever seen and I now looking back see a
lot of different you know signals about
that that maybe I could have and my
campaign could have done a better job
trying to figure out how to push back on
or make more transparent so that people
would understand you know boy I'll tell
you what that campaign of his they have
the best empty podium that anybody's
ever seen I mean get people to think and
even laugh a little bit about what was
happening in that campaign but you know
that that didn't happen soon enough and
it didn't happen in quite enough places
did you watch the Emmys last night at
all
I did I did but you wouldn't I think
many people may know you and your
husband are big fans of television
dramas and comedies and if you watched
as I'm sure many of you did you know
that The Handmaid's Tale was a big
winner and you you and I have actually
talked about that book in the past
written in 1985 dystopian work of
fiction that of course is now this
wildly popular TV series that is about a
liberal democracy slowly and very
definitively becoming a totalitarian
state which of course is sadly and
distressingly resonant at the moment and
that whole idea of the normalization of
the abnormal is terrifying by the way
doesn't it just bug you when people say
Trump is the this is the new normal I
mean we should never call it normal
right we should never say it's not
normal it's like the new abnormal it's
not the new normal but I mean seriously
it's it's terrifying and The Handmaid's
Tale resonates because of that you do
talk a lot about that in your book and
you you know from voter suppression from
the manipulation of the media to fake
news to everything else and just the
assault on the democratic institutions
we rely on that we need to be able to
trust it's scary and you of course you
know we'll get to the the fake news
Russia stuff in a minute but well look I
part of the reason I was motivated to
write this is because of what happened
at the inauguration and I write the
first chapter about what it felt like to
go to the inauguration and what a hard
decision it was but how I thought that
it was important to show continuity of
our government
I was certainly hoping to hear words of
reconciliation and bringing the country
together after you know a very divisive
camp
Payne didn't hear that and I felt very
uneasy about that inauguration I've been
to a bunch of them and I've been when
people I supported one and people I
supported lost but this was different
this was not a normal inauguration and
then it was made even more surreal with
the claims about the crowd size and the
introduction of alternative facts and
then I started thinking whoa this is
much more than just transfer from a
two-term Democratic president to an
unusual but Republican president and I
just couldn't I couldn't really grasp
how big a challenge they intended to
pose to facts and evidence and reason
all of which are fundamental to the
functioning of a democracy like ours and
so when I saw that I thought you know
this is much much bigger than any
transfer of presidential power that I'm
aware of in recent history because of
the assumptions that the new
administration was operating on and the
brazenness of their attempt to distort
reality and impose their version of
facts and truth on all the rest of us
despite what we saw with our own eyes
that bothered me greatly because I've
said before if I had lost you know to
another Republican candidate somebody
else had emerged from the Republican
primary I would have felt bad I would
have really been disappointed but I
wouldn't have worried about the
fundamental future of our country our
institutions
rule of law and this imperative of
reason that motivated our founders and
which is still absolutely essential so I
think this became a a resonant theme
with me because you can disagree about
policies you can disagree about all
kinds of things but you can't begin to
chip away at the basis of our
governments functioning and our
democratic norms without paying a very
big price so yes in the book I you you
won't be surprised
I mentioned The Handmaid's Tale I
mentioned in 1984 I mentioned brave new
world because I want readers to say ok I
may not agree with everything she says
but you know what I have to agree with
this fundamental premise that we can't
sacrifice truth and facts on the altar
of partisanship and the desire on the
part of a particular president and his
administration to control the news to
undermine the First Amendment to just
create this alternate reality because I
think the stakes of what we face in this
time are just profound and I've said
before and I will repeat it here I think
that this president and the people who
serve him on this alternative reality
track are posing a clear and present
danger to the future of our country
[Applause]
[Music]
and I think one of the most powerful
clearest most persuasive chapters in the
book is is the is the one about BOTS and
trolls and Russians and fake news and
you you begin that section of the book
I'm one of my know one of your favorite
books as brother's car Massa by
Dostoyevsky and you have a line from
Dostoevsky that begins the section of
the book when reason fails the devil
helps and and then of course you do talk
about trolls BOTS fake news conspiracy
theories and my favorite term from
Russia with no love but in all
seriousness this is an incredibly clear
connecting of dots based on what
evidence is now available presumably
there will be more coming out but anyway
thank you for that because it's it's
really essential that everybody read
that I also I've never had a chance to
thank you for something publicly that I
would like to thank you for now how many
of you were in Washington during what is
now infamously known as pizza gate we're
okay and those of you who've been to
politics and prose on Connecticut Avenue
know that the store is only a few doors
down from Comet ping-pong and you of
course we're onto this stuff because of
what was going on in the campaign before
a lot of us realized the extent of it
and you and I spoke shortly after the
election and you asked you knew that
comment was being targeted that politics
and prose and some of the other
businesses were being targeted and you
you actually said you were willing to
speak out about it for which we were
grateful at the time everybody thought
that we needed to all kind of lie low
for a bit the day that the gunman with
the assault weapon walked in to comment
on a Sunday afternoon December 4th about
an hour after that I you and I
communicated and I told you what was
going on and you responded instantly and
we were so supportive which was
incredibly helpful we were all on
lockdown on the entire block with police
running up and down the streets
and then and people don't know this a
few days after that you and your husband
said what can we do to support comet
can we buy pizzas and you bought I don't
know how many pizzas but it was a lot of
pizzas and sent them to a literacy
program an after-school Literacy Program
in DC which was never publicized and you
checked in on me a lot because we were
we were we weren't dealing with in the
same way comment ping-pong was but we
were also and you know getting trolled
in the whole nine yards and harassed my
calls I just can't tell you how
important it was for me for Brad for our
entire staff for our entire block for
the people at comment to know that you
and President Clinton were there for us
quietly and nobody note so I just I've
never had a chance to thank you publicly
and I I did want to do that so thank you
you know if I could just say a word cuz
we're in Washington and this horrible
chain of events happened here but this
is a terrible example of what can be
done by people who are malicious
unacquainted with the truth and pursuing
their own agendas whether it be
commercial advantage partisan advantage
or any other goal for those of you who
don't follow it or may not remember it
you know when john Podesta's emails were
stolen I hate the word hacked they were
stolen they were stolen by the Russians
and they were then through cutouts given
to WikiLeaks which is nothing more than
a tool of Putin and the Kremlin and
certainly people associated with Trump
knew about it because in August Roger
stone was tweeting about how John
Podesta would find himself you know in
the barrel some point ahead so on
October 7th one of the more infamous
days in the campaign the day started
with the director of Homeland Security
the Secretary jeh Johnson the Director
of National Intelligence Jim clapper
saying that with high confidence they
knew the Russians had been behind those
hacks those thefts of emails that
happened in the morning then the
Hollywood access tape broke a few hours
later and within one hour such an
amazing coincidence
WikiLeaks dumped all of John Podesta's
personal emails now if you read those
emails I think it's a little
embarrassing to admit they're very
anodyne even boring but because they
were the way that the Russians and their
allies whoever they turn out to be were
able to
we were able to generate constant
interest really was was two factors one
they sent the press on these wild goose
chases all over the place oh here comes
a hundred more here comes a thousand
more oh my gosh and then of course the
other was that they created the illusion
of transparency if you think you're
getting something from you know sort of
behind the screen maybe it's more
legitimate even though you're being
played by a bunch of Russians and the
psychology of it was brilliant and of
course it's part of the Russian
propaganda efforts something called
active measures which they've used in
many other settings not just in our
election well you can only go so far
with read these emails and listen to
people as in every campaign you can
imagine debate about what to do when and
who says what and all of that so they
had to be weaponized they had to have
elements plucked out and perverted in a
way that would be hard to imagine and
then sent back out into the you know
cyber virtual world so in one of the
emails John Podesta is talking about
pizza he's Italian and Greek I mean you
know and a very good cook and a very
good cook and yeah his risotto recipe is
still there if you want to see it and
I'm sure there's something very
nefarious about that risotto recipe so
so all of a sudden John's reading about
pizza and one of these really I consider
evil people in the media world and in
the online world out of whole cloth make
up this story that John Podesta and I
are running a child trafficking ring in
the basement of the comet pizza parlor
by the way there is no basement yeah
there is no basement
now you would think people would be
laughing like crazy shaking their heads
but if you migrate that crazy story to
Facebook posts to news outlets there are
people who will believe that including
this very unfortunate young man in North
Carolina who believed it it was meant to
be believed to influence voting even I
have to say I don't believe it was meant
to be believed to influence somebody to
pick up an ar-15 and drive from North
Carolina to Washington to liberate the
imaginary children from the imaginary
basement of the pizza parlor
but in came this young man believing
that he was on a mission because he saw
it on Facebook he saw it in other places
online he saw it in quote news outlets
and so he was there on a mission of
rescue people could have gotten killed
he shot his automatic weapon off inside
this pizza parlor the street where
politics and prose is was shut down
there was an active crime scene because
people who cared more about weaponizing
information making negative stories up
then the truth then facts or even public
safety and certainly any concern about
children was non-existent they were
determined to stimulate to propagate the
attitudes that would grab some people in
some states some congressional districts
some towns and counties so that they
would be saying well gosh you know if
Hillary Clinton and her campaign
Chairman are doing something like that
they should go to jail I can't vote for
that
that's the worst example but there are
so many other examples that were the
same pattern from stealing to giving to
WikiLeaks to propagating to weaponizing
into somebody's you know Google chain
into somebody's Facebook post and I
think it's one of the most serious
challenges we face going forward in
politics not just at the presidential
level but up and down because if we
don't get a handle on information that
is not just controversial protected by
the First Amendment
but aimed at spreading lies to the
extent that they can cause behavior like
we saw in this terrible instance it will
not stop and I'm glad that the Congress
and others are looking at Facebook and
Twitter and Google because they are the
vehicles that one of the very first
vehicles to deliver this kind of
information to people but I was just
terrified for Lissa and Brad and all
their employees and everybody on that
street because I I could see what the
trafficking of that absolutely horrible
information was meant to do and it got
out of hand and we were just fortunate
that nobody was injured and what and and
it you know it keeps going but the
consolation and there is consolation is
that the outpouring of support from our
community was unbelievable for comment
for politics and prose people feel
tremendous ownership about their
communities and you know and I might
just say Mike Pence at that time was
living about a mile away in a rented
house and before he could move into the
vice president we'd see his motorcade up
and down up did he once think about
coming in buying a slice of pizza buying
of course not but the community
has been fantastic and any of you who've
you know come to a comet or come to putt
P&P
after that thank you it really made a
huge difference okay I want to be a
little lighter for a second here so
there's a very funny moment in the book
where when you say that President Obama
told you don't try to be hip you're a
grandma just just be yourself and my
question is what did he what do you
think he was you're gonna run off to a
SoulCycle class or take a mixology
course or to chia pudding I mean what
was he what was he what was he worried
about oh there's probably so many
examples that I know I'm just wondering
cuz President Obama I think it's okay
honestly know that he he was an
extraordinarily supportive and helpful
friend throughout the whole campaign he
would call me periodically and he would
say are you getting enough sleep
are you you know eating well I'd say oh
I think I'm getting enough sleep and
they could meeting well and then he'd
say well are you exercising I'd say well
you know I think I'm getting enough
sleep and I think I'm eating well but he
he really you know stayed up with me
stayed up with the campaign and I can't
remember which which of the incidents he
might have been referring to but he was
always just in my corner and had my back
throughout the whole you know 18 months
or nearly two years okay so you love
words she's a great writer herself by
the way you love words your husband love
words did anybody see President
Clinton's guest crossword puzzle in The
New York Times a few months ago that was
pretty cool so we're gonna play a little
word game if that's okay you up for this
okay it's gonna get its have you ever
heard of the game boxers or briefs
what boxers or briefs like if you're a
guy do you like boxers or briefs so
we're gonna play that game but don't
worry you don't have to answer that
question
and I'm gonna give you two words and you
just have to without thinking this book
is very revealing but you know you
people know now exactly which kind of
hot sauce you like and they know that
you do deep breathing and all that stuff
so we're just gonna help him out with a
few more things and I'm gonna give you
two words you're gonna just immediately
whichever one is most suits you you're
gonna answer okay ready yeah I do have
to say a word about hot sauce first okay
help I mean I have carried hot sauce
since 1992 I just want you to know it is
true and there were people who were
actually accusing me of just making that
up it's not made up no it's not made up
but I do spend probably more time than I
should in the book talking about hot
sauce so anybody want any
recommendations just let me know okay
it's it's true for as long as I've known
you hot sauce has been in your purse
absolutely true we can all vouch for her
okay you ready so two words you got it
okay
it's gonna get progressively a little
harder but we're not going to do too
many of them okay so - your coffee
coffee beach or beach or mountains what
beach or mountains beach okay shower or
bath well these are all really unfair
and that is particularly unfair easy
because I mean really it depends upon
how much time you have okay that's fine
okay
Pilates or yoga yoga vodka or Chardonnay
again it depends upon how much to pipe
you
[Applause]
history or mystery Oh historical
mysteries how was that okay Putin or
Trump
yeah well I have to take that under
advisement for the following reasons I
ran against both of them
excellent I was gonna say Comey or Comey
who are you also ran again okay I think
well we're gonna take some audience
questions I have we you guys did great
questions there resilience of them a lot
of them were similar and first of all
lots of people just said thank you
and I could go through a lot of cards
like I said thank you quite a few also
related to young people and young women
especially in getting into politics so
here's one and here's one that there's
there two that are sort of similar what
advice would you give to a young woman
who wants to go into politics and here's
another one that's similar would you
encourage your daughter to enter
politics if she were interested but you
knew she'd experienced the same level of
sexism you've encountered during your
political career well let me answer this
question in general because I would say
the same thing to any young woman who
were to ask I'd say look even though I
write at length about the challenges
that women in politics face and point
out it's not just me and it's not just
Democratic women it is unfortunately
still a very very tough double standard
I would still say that if you are
willing to enter politics either as a
candidate as a campaign staffer as a you
know person in government and public
service because that's how I view the
the bigger definition of politics you
just have to be prepared and try to have
the confidence without being walled off
without being you know too defensive and
it's easy for me to say I've been all of
those things at various points in my
public career but it's a really great
experience
it is important to have more women in
politics and it is important that we we
all support each other in the political
arena you know one of the great quotes
that I have loved for years as Eleanor
Roosevelt saying for any woman who
enters the public arena she needs to
grow skin as thick as the hide of a
rhinoceros because you will be judged by
everything from you know your hair to
your voice to whether you are married or
not married whether you have children or
don't have children so it's a constant
gotcha game and you have to be clear
about why you're going into politics and
what you hope to achieve through your
your efforts but I I say in the book you
know by pulling the curtain back and
talking about how hard it is I don't
want to discourage anybody I want people
to be more aware of it so we can call it
out for what it is I don't you know but
this is common across every walk of life
and there's a there's a fascinating
article in The New York Times sports
section today about women in sports and
the grief they take because of their
voice and as somebody who has been
called everything when it comes to well
everything but I'm thinking particularly
about voice it really struck home with
me you you know you just have to be
prepared you have to have at least a
sense of humor to get through some of
what you're going to face but if you are
prepared if you educate yourself if you
are surrounded by good you know good
supporters friends family people who can
tell you the truth you know like Lissa
started off saying she told me was a
terrible idea to write this book I am
grateful for that because she's a friend
and you need friends who tell you when
things are good
when things aren't so good I think it's
really important so I've got this new
organization called onward together that
I've started and and really the primary
purpose is to support groups that are
recruiting young people especially young
women training them funding them we also
highlight and lift up wonderful groups
like indivisible which is leading the
charge to keep the keep our attention
where it needs to be like we've got to
stop this latest attempt to repeal the
Affordable Care Act that is going on so
I think there's a lot of good work to be
done and and onward together is really
interesting because that was you and
Howard Dean you met with Howard Dean
earlier our friend Judith McHale who
were so instrumental in really thinking
outside the box about how to bring young
people get them involved engaged them
support them because they know a lot
more than people like well I mean it was
so great after after the election one of
the things that kind of you know got me
out of bed and moving again were the
stories I would hear people were called
to oh there's this new young group that
one of your campaign staffers has
started called run for something and
it's aiming at recruiting more young
people or there's a group there's a
group called swing left they're gonna
try to flip the house or a group that
I've worked with before emerge America
which has a great record of electing
women Color of Change which focuses on
you know African American young people
getting them into politics and doing
some of that work so I felt like there's
so much we can do because at the end of
the day and I just have to say this and
hope you help me figure out how we're
gonna make it happen
everything we do we can we can write
books if we can speak out we can go to
protest we can recruit people to run for
office but if we don't get people to
vote starting in Virginia and New Jersey
then in 2018 we're not going to turn
this around and it is gratifying to see
how many people who were never thinking
about getting into office now are a few
more audience questions do you really
keep that hot sauce in your bag also we
love you I think you already answered
that we appreciate you
what should the Democratic Party run on
in the next election it's not an easy
question well I think it has to be both
economic justice and social justice and
you know we have the better side of the
argument about how to make the economy
grow to be inclusive to lift incomes
provide opportunities we just have to
keep plugging away at it and not you
know not get discouraged and we have to
keep calling out the other side whose
answer to everything is tax cuts for the
wealthy you know I almost can imagine a
scene and you know some Republican
members home and the kid calls out and
says hey you know I don't feel good well
take a tax cut for the wealthy and we'll
wake you in the morning see how you're
doing because it answers everything ever
whatever ails you tech I mean that's
really the the inside story of what's
going on with this attempt to repeal the
Affordable Care Act it's to free up
money for tax cuts for the wealthy so we
have to keep talking over and over again
and not get discouraged because
sometimes we think we make a great
argument but it doesn't you know take
the first time we have to keep going at
at time and time again but we can't be
promoting and standing up for economic
justice to the exclusion of turning our
back on all the progress we've made in
moving people forward on civil rights
and women's rights and gay
and human right so I just don't I don't
buy I don't buy this false dichotomy you
can only be for the economy or you can
only be for people's civil rights that's
ridiculous we want everybody to rise we
want everybody to have a better
opportunity and future going forward
well let's let's talk about women for a
second because we both care about women
and I think most people here do just
getting back to the handmade still the
sub the the other big subtext of The
Handmaid's Tale is how women treat other
women especially women with power women
with power with women who don't have
power women who've been marginalized and
it can be very cruel the way women treat
other women you've experienced a little
about a little bit of that yourself
obviously right well yeah I'm glad you
asked about it I said because I write
about this and I'll start with a
conversation I had shortly before
announcing that I was going to run and
it was with Sheryl Sandberg somebody
that I've known for a long time and
really appreciate the work that she's
done with lean on with the research
working with professors at Stanford at
the University of Pennsylvania
marshaling again facts and evidence
about what actually happens in women's
lives how were perceived how we perceive
ourselves so she said she wished that
everyone who read lean on understood
what she thought was one of the major
takeaways from that book which was that
the more professionally successful a man
becomes he becomes more likeable and you
know what's coming the more
professionally successful a woman
becomes she becomes less likeable
because our you know our stereotypes our
presumptions about what's appropriate
and not appropriate are just so powerful
I mean they are rooted
in our DNA they go back millennia and so
you say to yourself okay if that's the
case then what can we do about it
the second point she made equally
provocative is that women are liked much
more viewed much more favorably when
they are in service to someone else so I
was in service to our country and
service to President Obama as a member
of his cabinet in his first term I left
the State Department with a 69 percent
approval rating people thought I was
doing a good job and I was doing a good
job because they could see me you know
standing up for our country standing
beside the president trying to solve
problems and what was fascinating to me
it was really horrifying but fascinating
was how effective it was to just begin
to knock that down and to get to the
point where oh gosh we don't know what
we think about her and Sheryl made this
very clear she said you know if you are
in service to someone else you are
viewed favorably so in the workplace if
you go to your employer and you say I
really think Lissa should get a raise
she's been working so hard you get
points because you're viewed as somebody
who is a real team player looking out
for your colleagues if you go and say
you know I've been working really hard
and I'd like to be considered for a
raise if you're a woman it's held
against you if you're a man it's not and
these are just attitudes that are deeply
embedded in how we see women in the
public arena now I won the women's vote
but I lost the white women's vote I got
more white women's votes however than
President Obama got in 2012 so the
problem is one that Democratic
nominees have to contend with have to
figure out how to communicate
breakthrough better now I personally
believe that I was doing well enough
with white women even Republican white
women before the Comey letter but it
stopped my momentum and it played into
the concerns that women have about
whether they are making a mistake with
their vote
I started going door-to-door in politics
many many years ago and I was always
surprised when I would knock on a door
and a woman would answer and I'd say you
know I'm here for this candidate and let
me say well I I just don't know enough I
don't want to make a mistake and so that
was my personal experience and of course
taking it to the the last month of this
campaign all of a sudden people are
being told mm you know what something's
going on they you know they're gonna
investigator again or whatever we could
see that a lot of women in particular
turned away they were discouraged I
don't blame them they didn't know what
to believe I mean it was outrageous what
happened but so you got to see how women
are trying to do what they think of as
the right thing for themselves and for
their family they're often under
pressure from people around them a lot
of anecdotal evidence about that so when
a woman runs just to work extra hard to
convince other women that she can do the
job that she is running for and we've
made progress not enough in the Congress
and the Senate way not enough in
governor's offices but getting people to
feel comfortable at the presidential
level is still a challenge there's some
statistics in my book
that even among Democratic women and men
it's not 80 or 90% who think they'd like
to see a woman president it's in the
high 60s for women it's in the 40s for
men which is a lot more than it is for
Republicans who just have a hard time
thinking about a woman in the White
House so these are complicated
psychological emotional political
economic issues and if you think there's
just one answer you're probably going to
be wrong and so we have to look at a
much broader set of responses and
appeals to persuade women to vote for
other women and then to try to make
solidarity around that um one of the
nice things in the book though is the
the incredible sense of support you have
from your own friends suspect men and
women but especially women you talk
about your girlfriends being so and
that's been true forever for you you've
had these friends friendships that have
gone on and thank goodness for that
right because women really do come
through for other women when they're at
least close to each other next question
from the audience and we're coming close
to our time but we'll try to do these
quickly actually there's no question but
I'm drinking Chardonnay with you in
solidarity can you demonstrate our
alternate nostril breathing anyway I
really do highly recommend it it's not
that hard
what is all google it okay she's not
gonna demonstrate it but you get the
idea what has been the most fulfilling
part of your life so far my whole life
what has been the most fulfilling part
of her I guess yes whole life so far
yeah no I mean my family and my friends
obviously for me and doing work that I
believed in and that I thought made a
difference I write in the book about I
write about my marriage and my husband I
write about my daughter and motherhood
about my mother I write about my friends
because at the end of the day everybody
has disappointments everybody has losses
I viewed this book as much about
resilience as about running for
president because at for me having the
support and the encouragement that I got
from my family during the campaign and
certainly in the aftermath and from my
friends you made all the difference as
to you know how I felt and whether I
could you know sort of summon the energy
and the commitment to continue to play a
public role on behalf of causes and
values that I care about so I I think
I'm a very look I'm a very fortunate
person and I want others no matter what
happens to you in life
to understand that there are ways to get
up and keep going and don't give up on
yourself don't give up on your friends
on people you care about there's a a
serious and question that I think we all
are distressed about what is your advice
for federal workers facing the internal
destruction of their agencies especially
at EPA and state and we miss you
Wow you know I am so distressed because
there's so much experience and expertise
among federal employees across our
government and it's been hard one it has
been years in the making and there seems
to be a total disregard even a contempt
on the part of many in this
administration for what federal workers
know and what they've done and the
advice that they can give you know the
other night I was talking with Rachel
Maddow about this when it came to the
State Department
and I I I have such a high regard for so
many of the you know Foreign Service
officers and civil servants that I
worked with at all levels in the State
Department and I think about some of the
crises that we confront like North Korea
and you know people who know the
language know the history have
experience in the Korean Peninsula and
China and Japan they should be sitting
in meetings with the highest levels of
this administration providing advice and
information that could be useful on
behalf of our country there is such a
disdain though for federal workers so I
guess I would say if you can stick it
out stick it out because the tide has to
turn and
if we can take back one or both houses
of Congress in 2018 you will have people
you can talk to again but I know how
difficult that is because I know what's
happened to people that I worked with in
the State Department
you know just really being frozen out
and demeaned mistreated so I know it's
not easy for me to say this but I don't
want us to lose the decades really if
you added it all up the thousands of
years of experience in the EPA in the
State Department in the Labor Department
in a lot of the places that are being
targeted by the administration and so I
hope that we can maintain a a corps of
experienced public servants in our
government because at some point they're
gonna need you and the country is gonna
need you and I hope you're still there
we are gonna have to wrap it up
unfortunately I want one last audience
question though was what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream
oh the hard questions it my favorite
flavor I guess chocolate anything with
chocolate in it but I did want to I did
want to just say a few more words about
the future because that's really what
I'm most focused on I think it it was
important to figure out what happened in
order to be better prepared and you know
some of it is institutional some of it
is attitudinal but it can all have an
effect on not just our politics but on
who we are as Americans and I'm
concerned that a lot of a lot of
permission has been given to people to
be
very bigoted to be prejudiced to lash
out at others based on religion or
gender or race and every other kind of
identifying characteristic and so I I
think it's very important that we not
grow weary in standing up for what we
see as core American values not
permitting the clock to be turned back
and people's progress to be reversed you
know there's a lot to be proud of that
the resistance and people in the
resistance are doing every single day
and of course the great contrast that I
write about between the inauguration on
a Friday and the women's March on a
Saturday
and holding the line on repealing the
Affordable Care Act and saving insurance
for millions of Americans is a really
big deal and and there's ways for
everybody to play a role not everyone
will start an organization or run for
office but everybody can be sure you
your friends everybody you know is
registered to vote you can be sure that
if you have a free weekend you can go
canvass and this year in Virginia or in
New Jersey you can start looking to see
strategically where your vote will count
the most because in the 2018 election
there gonna be some very competitive
seats I won 24 congressional districts
that have a Republican member of
Congress in them and so thinking hard
about how you can support people who
stick their necks out and and decide
they're going to run you know going
online to combat untruths and and
attacks and vitriol you know be one of
those people who is standing up and and
and tweeting back or posting something
on Facebook or making it clear that you
know people are not going to be given a
pass if they are promoting falsehoods
and and personal attacks and and you
know really horrible positions whether
it's white supremacy or neo-nazis or Ku
Klux Klan or whatever it might be that
you know we're not going to let that go
unanswered because it's critical that
people have a sustained commitment to
taking our country back in the way that
we believe it is at its best in order to
have the kind of future that we believe
is possible and no one has more of a
stake in that than young people and so
for me I'm going to spend a lot of my
time you know supporting young people
talking with young people encouraging
people to understand the power of their
votes which is still the great
unrealized opportunity in American
politics and to keep having cross
relationships that you know cross every
line that is meant to divide us instead
obliterate them and to lead integrated
full lives with each other and to be
kind of the rebuke to those who want to
divide us and undermine us and I am very
optimistic I mean at the end of the day
and at the end of my book you know I
talk about love and kindness something
that we talked a lot about in the
campaign which you know was something
that was my attempt to respond to the
you know the the sight of some of the
rallies on the other side you know the
the veins bulging and necks and the
yelling and the the pushing and even the
violence and you know come on you know
that that's not who we are that's not
who we should be so at the end I talked
a lot about what I think we can do and
should do going forward
and at the end at the end of the book
I'm optimistic because I really believe
that you know we always summon up the
energy and get ourselves you know
focused right and keep moving toward
that more perfect union and I'm gonna do
everything I can to help us get there
and
you start the book with Harriet Tubman
keep going which is been a favorite of
yours but in this book by the way is
really in some ways a collection of your
favorite
sources of inspiration quotes and
phrases and I thought that first of all
thank you for not going quietly into the
night well you know I wanted
[Applause]
you know I just wanted to say that none
of us none of us can afford to go
quietly away we need our voices we need
our energy and yes I really do believe
it takes a village or in this case it
takes a country to get us back on the
right track and it's very consistent
with my belief that we have to bring
people together to work together in this
you know this children's version of it
takes a village which is intended to say
you know what we all have to work
together and maybe you think it's
politically correct I think it is
America at its best and so we're not
going to go anywhere we're still going
to be here and still fighting and still
moving and and let me just end with with
a couple of quotes you've been you know
by by using your voice by writing this
book by being who you are by supporting
onward together and starting on work
together you are a model for a lot of
people who wonder what they can do and
and I just want to end with a few quotes
that you include in your book I think
that we can all turn to as we resist
insist persist and enlist Nelson Mandela
the greatest glory is not in never
falling but in rising every time you
fall pope john xxiii concern yourself
not with what you tried and failed but
what is still possible to do one of your
favorites TS Eliot there's only the
trying Ralph Waldo Emerson life goes on
but here's the best one and we will end
on this one and I think this one is most
appropriate for this evening most
appropriate for you and what you've done
for this country for the last 25 years
and will for the next 25 plus years
from Maya Angelou but still I rise thank
you all very much for coming
[Applause]